Mit Untertiteln
von SWISS TXT
Ich habe euch lieb.
- Danke, gleichfalls.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss. - Tschau.
Trag dir Sorge! Achte auf dich!
Sie alle gingen auf und davon.
Buen dia.
- Salud.
Seit über einem Jahr nun leben unsere
Auswanderer in ihrer neuen Heimat.
Wie haben sie ihr erstes Jahr
in der Fremde erlebt?
Danke schön.
- Guten Appetit.
Sind sie heimisch geworden?
Wir haben sie nochmals besucht.
* Lockere Musik *
Alles begann mit einem Traum:
eine Posada mit Gästehäusern,
Restaurant und Pool -
mitten in der Weite von Uruguay.
Jetzt haben wir die Kraft noch.
Mit 60 mögen wir das
vielleicht nicht mehr machen.
Ein neues Projekt
für die zweite Lebenshälfte.
Während des Baus
lebten Susanne und Ruedi
im Container
direkt auf der Baustellea
Fast wie im Skilager, oder?
Familie Almeida aus Turbenthal
gab ihr
florierendes Bed and Breakfast weiter
und zog mit ihren drei Kindern
an die Westküste Kanadas.
In der Provinz Nova Scotia übernahm
sie ein Motel aus den 60er-Jahren.
Das ist ein bisschen
eine Wundertüte.
Ui, meine Güte! One moment.
Alles musste perfekt sein.
Trotz Hochsaison renovierten sie
sämtliche Zimmer des Motels.
Leben an der Nordsee.
Familie Kunz aus dem Baselbiet
übernahm eine Imbissbude
direkt am Meer.
Auch Oma Susanne und die Zwillinge
Timo und Noemi wanderten mit aus.
Nur der älteste Sohn blieb zurück.
Wie geht es Familie Kunz
und den anderen Auswanderern heute?
Herbst 2020.
Die ganze Nacht ist Kevin,
der älteste Sohn der Familie Kunz,
durchgeblocht.
In einem Stück von Basel
bis an die Nordsee.
Einige Male schon ist er die Strecke
rauf- und runtergefahren.
Doch die heutige Ankunft ...
- Ah, du hast es geschafft.
... ist eine für immer.
- Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Super!
Mach nicht so Faxen!
Auch Kevin
will an der Nordsee heimisch werden.
Alles gut?
- Ja. Bei dir? - Ja.
Tipptopp.
- Na, hast du es geschafft?
Sali.
- Super.
Schön, dass du da bist!
- Sali. Geht es gut?
Gut gefahren? Gut.
-Langsam.
Meine Güte! - Seht ihr,
wie perfekt es geladen ist?
Besser geht nicht.
Hei, ei, ei, ei, ei!
- Die musste mit, oder?
Das ist klar. Die Eisbärdecke.
- Eisbärdecke.
Die ist an deiner Seite,
seit du drei warst.
Seit du ein kleiner Junge warst.
Wir nehmen einfach alles rauf.
Alles in sein Zimmer.
- Dort reinstellen, oder?
Doch kaum angekommen,
macht der Vater Druck.
Kevin wird sofort
im Imbisswagen gebraucht.
Um 11.30 Uhr machen wir auf.
Jetzt müssen wir laden.
Dann alles einräumen, vorbraten.
Wir haben genug Arbeit.
Langweilig wird es uns nicht.
Kaffee muss gemacht werden,
das Eis ...
Ich zeige dir das gerne.
Ja, ich glaube, man muss
Familie und Arbeit trennen können.
Das muss man schon trennen können.
Er ist halt der Big Boss.
Zu Hause zwar auch,
aber auch im Geschäft.
Wir haben schon zusammengearbeitet.
Das ging gut.
Wir kommen uns
nicht so in die Quere.
Auch wenn er manchmal stresst.
Oder, Vater?
- Ja.
* Lockere Musik *
Am Kutterhafen,
10 Min. von zu Hause entfernt,
steht Kunzens Imbissbude:
"Küsten-Imbiss".
* Lockere Musik *
Grill anmachen?
- Du kannst anzünden, ja.
Nein.
- Nein.
Mach auf das Kleinste. Das.
Und jetzt der.
Nein. Nicht drücken.
Reindrücken, dann kommt es.
Ah, länger.
- Nein, nicht drücken.
Länger draufbleiben.
- Bist ja drauf.
Aber ...
- Ja, draufbleiben.
Jetzt ist er an?
- Ja, dann aber auf klein.
Dann kannst du die anbraten.
- Tipptopp.
Warum geht das nicht?
- Mit dem Fusspedal.
Ich bin drauf mit dem Fuss.
- Mit etwas Kraft aufdrücken.
Mit der anderen Hand ...
- Ich bin drauf mit dem Fuss.
Mit der anderen Hand noch dran.
Jawohl.
Sehr gut. Super.
- So schwer.
Moin.
- Moin.
Obwohl noch keine Kunden
vor dem Wagen anstehen,
bricht Hektik aus.
Kunz?
Moin.
Ja.
Viermal Currywurst und Pommes
auf 12.30 Uhr?
Also, bereite ich vor.
Danke dir. Tschüss. Danke.
Vorbereiten?
- Muss ich. Sie rufen auch an.
Das ist ... Das ist ...
1.49 Euro.
* Lachen *
Viermal Currywurst mit Pommes.
Immer öfter bestellen Kunden
Würste und Pommes telefonisch.
Guten Appetit.
Es wurde Zeit, dass Kevin
ins Familienunternehmen einsteigt.
Eigentlich war er fix in
das Auswanderungsprojekt eingeplant.
Die Bratwurst im Brötchen.
- Mit Mayo, eh, Ketchup, bitte.
So jedenfalls war es gedacht,
als die Familie vor über einem Jahr
kurz vor ihrer Auswanderung stand.
Schauen wir zurück.
Das Eigenheim in Läufelfingen/BL
ist bereits verkauft.
Entschuldigung.
Komm, geht doch.
So, komm.
- Ja.
Jetzt wird es geräumt.
Komm, mach mal!
- Schieb zu mir!
* Knarren *
Ja, ja, das macht nichts.
Hopp.
Nein, ich nehme nicht an.
Da ist die Bettwäsche drin.
Auch Grossmutter Susanne
zieht mit in den Norden.
Sie will nach ihren Enkeln
Timo und Noemi schauen,
während deren Eltern
im Imbisswagen arbeiten.
Alles weg.
- Was weg?
Schauen wir mal, wie es herauskommt.
Aber auf jeden Fall freue ich mich.
Man hat auch das Gefühl,
dass man noch gebraucht wird.
Nebenan sortieren Mutter Brigitte
und Tochter Noemi Kleider aus.
Ich nehme an, das behältst du?
- Natürlich.
Ja, ja, jetzt zählt es.
Das war jetzt
die letzte Nacht in unserem Haus.
In ein paar Wochen
sollen Vater Sacha und Sohn Kevin
gemeinsam hinter dem Grill
im Imbisswagen stehen.
So der Plan.
Das ist ein neuer Lebensabschnitt
für uns.
Und das Schöne ist,
dass wir als ganze Familie gehen.
Ich denke,
das ist sicher auch etwas Schönes.
Ein Familienunternehmen also.
Doch es kommt anders
* Lachen *
Türe auf. Danke schön.
Kevin bleibt in der Schweiz.
Zu sehr hängt er an seinem Umfeld
und seinen Freunden.
Als er uns sagte,
dass er nicht komme,
war das schon ...
Ich fand das schon sehr schlimm.
Wir sind doch eine Familie
und waren immer zusammen.
Das beschäftigte mich schon.
Aber ja, wir mussten sagen:
"Er ist alt genug."
"Er ist volljährig."
Wir konnten ihn nicht zwingen.
Umso schöner,
dass er jetzt hier ist.
Ja.
Ich wohnte allein und war irgendwann
alleine in der Wohnung.
An einem Samstagabend -
meine Freunde hatten Pläne -
war ich zu Hause und dachte:
"Irgendwie läuft nichts."
Da dachte ich:
"Vielleicht fehlt die Familie."
Dann kam Corona.
Da war ich auch sehr viel alleine.
Kein Training.
Und dann ...
Ja, in der Zeit, als Corona war,
fasste ich den Entschluss,
die Wohnung zu künden
und nach Deutschland zu gehen.
Ohne Corona
wäre ich wohl noch in der Schweiz.
Nur noch alles ins Auto packen.
Dann geht es für die Eltern
Sacha und Brigitte Kunz endlich los.
Die Zwillinge Timo und Noemi
bleiben noch
bei ihrer Grossmutter in der Schweiz,
bis das Schuljahr zu Ende ist.
Geht der auch?
- Dachtest du, er bleibt? - Ja.
Der Abschied von den Kindern
ist schon schwierig. Das ist so.
Ja.
Tschüss. Also ...
- Tschüss.
Ist gut?
- Ja.
Tschüss, Timo. Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Es ist nicht lange. Okay?
- Ja.
Okay ...
Macht es bitte kurz!
- Tschüss.
Nicht schon wieder.
Nein, ist okay.
Tschüss zusammen.
- Tschüss.
Zusammen mit der Grossmutter
kommen Timo und seine Schwester Noemi
in sechs Wochen nach.
Es war nicht ganz einfach.
Sie waren ja doch 900 km weg.
Es war kein schöner Moment,
als wir uns verabschieden mussten.
Das habe ich noch nie so erlebt.
(Timo) Wir haben sie auch vermisst.
Und ja, es war schlimm.
Es war schon ziemlich hart.
Wir konnten es leider
nicht anders machen.
Wir konnten nicht später anfangen
bzw. übernehmen.
Wir wollten den Kindern
aber ermöglichen,
das Schuljahr fertig zu machen.
Ich denke,
wir haben das gut gemeistert.
Es war sicher nicht schön,
aber wir hatten keine andere Wahl.
An der Nordsee,
gut 900 km von Basel entfernt,
liegt Dorum, eine Ortschaft
mit rund 3'500 Einwohnern.
Hier haben sich die Baselbieter
ein Haus mit drei Wohnungen gekauft.
Jetzt sind wir halt
wieder im Norden.
Ja.
Endlich zu Hause.
- Endlich zu Hause.
Das ist so. Auf den Moment
haben wir schon lange gewartet.
Endlich am Ziel -
nach 10 Std. auf der Autobahn.
Warten! So ist gut.
Der Lapplandhund Falco
und die heilige Birmakatze Roxy
haben die lange Fahrt
gut überstanden.
Hallo. Grüss dich. Sacha.
- Grüss dich. Hannes.
Freut mich.
Freunde und Nachbarn
erwarten sie bereits.
Alles gut?
André von Gegenüber
hilft mit seiner Familie,
die Möbel zusammenzubauen.
Die Schweizer haben ihn
vor ein paar Monaten kennengelernt,
als sie das Haus renovierten.
Es ist ein Heimkommen. Es ist schön.
Freunde, die warten und helfen.
Das ist cool.
Das ist wirklich, wirklich cool.
Umzug gelungen.
# Dort oben bin ich geboren.
# Und hier gehöre ich hin.
Ebenso herzlich geht es weiter.
Die Schlüsselübergabe
für den Imbisswagen
feiern Brigitte und Sacha
mit einem Fest.
Der Imbisswagen steht bereits
seit 25 Jahren an der Nordsee.
Der Vorbesitzer
gibt den Schlüssel weiter.
Wir möchten unseren Betrieb abgeben
an die Familie Kunz aus der Schweiz.
Darf ich euch mal nach vorne bitten?
* Applaus *
Ihr seid jetzt die neuen Chefs.
Ja, das sind die neuen Chefs.
Und ein Chef
braucht auch einen Schlüssel.
Darf ich den übergeben?
Bitte schön, Sacha, der Schlüssel.
Geht vorsichtig damit um.
- Machen wir.
Man hört es: Wir kommen
aus der Schweiz. Das ist so.
Nächsten Freitag
werden wir hier eröffnen.
Ich bedanke mich schon im Voraus
und wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Tag.
Danke.
Bitte schön.
# My Bonnie is over the ocean.
Es war ein grosser
und auch ein schöner Auftakt.
Das war wirklich ...
Auch mit dem Chor, der noch sang,
dem Shantychor.
Das war natürlich
ein Neuanfang für uns,
der eigentlich
nicht besser hätte sein können.
Hallo.
- Hallo. Herzlich willkommen.
Danke. Zum Wohl.
- Danke schön.
Den Schlüssel haben wir.
* Brigitte lacht. *
Als wir den Rundgang machten
und zu jeder Bude bzw. jedem
Besitzer oder Verkäufer gingen,
die dort waren, hat man sich
schon auch seine Gedanken gemacht:
"Wie wird man wohl aufgenommen?"
Jetzt ist es einfach sensationell.
Jetzt ist es familiär.
Es ist wirklich wie eine Familie
auf der Platte.
Das war eigentlich
unsere einzige Angst:
wie wir aufgenommen werden.
Aber das ist jetzt kein Thema mehr.
* Lockere Musik *
Diesen Sommer im Emmental.
Die Uruguay-Auswanderer sind
auf Besuch in ihrer alten Heimat.
Für Handwerker Ruedi Althaus gibt es
auch hier immer etwas zu schrauben.
Das ist das Schöne,
wenn man mal hier ist:
Freunde zu sehen und natürlich
die Familie, die Jungs.
Es ist schön, wenn man das kann.
Während ihres Aufenthaltes
wohnt das Ehepaar
im Studio ihres Einfamilienhauses.
Eigentlich wollten sie
schon im Frühjahr auf Besuch kommen,
doch Corona
machte ihre Pläne zunichte.
Es machte mir schon zu schaffen.
Ich hatte schon Heimweh.
Die Jungs fehlten mir.
Meinem Vater ging es nicht so gut.
Auch wenn man weiss,
dass man nicht in der Nähe ist,
hat man dann doch plötzlich
das Gefühl, die Distanz sei riesig
und es ist nicht möglich,
nach Hause zu kommen.
Susannes Vater geht es wieder besser.
So können sie den Besuch bei Familie
und Freunden einfach nur geniessen.
Frau Hüsi, kannst du dir das
kurz ansehen? - Ja.
Unsere Ferienplanung.
Sind wir hier in den Ferien?
Das hier ist unsere Ferienplanung:
wann wir wo sind.
Wir wollen in den drei Wochen
möglichst viele Leute sehen.
Unsere Planung zeigt,
wann wir wo eingeladen sind,
um nicht doppelt zu fahren
oder einen Leertag zu haben.
Das wäre doof.
- Dann hätten wir einen Tag nichts.
Das wäre auch ... Ja.
- Nein, nein.
Super so.
Das hier funktioniert nicht.
Das geht hier nicht, nein.
Die Emmentaler haben eine ereignis-
reiche Auswanderung hinter sich.
Vor über einem Jahr
räumte das Ehepaar Althaus
sein grosses Einfamilienhaus
in Schüpbach.
Hier hatte Ruedi
seine Kindheit verbracht.
Seine Eltern
besassen eine Schreinerei.
Jahrelang
hatte er als Bauschreiner gearbeitet.
Später ging er mit der Swisscoy
in den Kosovo.
Wir geben viel auf.
Das Geregelte, die Sicherheit ...
Das haben wir nicht mehr.
Und Präsenz- und Arbeitszeiten
werden sicher auch länger sein -
hoffen wir, denn dann läuft es auch.
Das gibt man alles auf.
Aber ich denke ...
... die Freiheit,
die man dann hat ...
Du mit dir selber -
das noch mal erleben.
Das war, denke ich, bei Susu und mir
der springende Punkt,
um das zu machen.
Seit 30 Jahren
sind Susanne und Ruedi ein Paar.
Wer möchte gerne?
Wer schneidet die Spareribs?
Noch einmal Schweizer Alltag
mit ihren drei Jungs geniessen.
Michu, Gesundheit. Luki, Gesundheit.
Schön, seid ihr hier!
Zum Wohl zusammen.
Gesundheit zusammen.
Es ist schön, dass sie hier sind.
Das ist super.
Solche Events
werde ich sicher vermissen.
Man stellt sich einfach vor,
wie es werden könnte.
Aber wie es dann wird,
sehen wir, wenn es so weit ist.
Ich weiss nicht ...
- Es ist nicht greifbar.
Nein, wirklich nicht.
- Einfach auf Distanz.
Es sind so die kleinen Dinge.
Und einfach ...
Ja, das Zuhause.
Das ist halt schon ...
Das fehlt dann schon.
Spontane Zusammenkünfte
wird es künftig nicht mehr geben.
Doch Besuche der Söhne in Uruguay
sind schon fix geplant.
Ja, Corona hat uns da einen Strich
durch die Rechnung gemacht.
Das machte mir schon Mühe.
Man kann nicht sagen, weil wir ...
... unsere Jungs nicht so oft sehen,
machen wir die Auswanderung nicht,
ziehen wir die Pläne,
die wir haben, nicht durch.
Es ist ja ein Traum.
Sie haben ihr Leben hier auch.
Und wenn die Emotionen
nicht ab und zu hochkämen -
sei das bei Susu oder mir -,
wenn da nichts käme,
das ganze Jahr, das man weg ist,
hätten wir ja vorher
kein Familienleben gehabt.
Das soll kommen
und auch Platz haben.
Auf der südlichen Halbkugel
in Uruguay
beginnt Ende April der Herbst.
Die Zukunft von Ruedi und Susanne
liegt weit ab von
der städtischen Hektik Montevideos.
Die Emmentaler wandern ins
ländliche Uruguay, in die Pampa, aus.
In der Nähe
von Colonia del Sacramento
haben sie ein Stück Land gekauft.
Ruedi ist vorausgereist.
Susanne folgt in ein paar Wochen.
Fürs Erste hat er
ein Zimmer im Städtchen gemietet.
Ich dich auch.
Tschüss. Tschau. Tschau.
Kaum angekommen, hat er auch schon
seine erste Planungssitzung.
Mit dabei:
Alex, die Auswanderungsberaterin.
Heute hilft sie übersetzen.
- Da vorne rechts ist der Eingang.
Gut.
Vor zwei Jahren hatte sie den
Schweizern das Grundstück vermittelt.
Zur Besprechung
ist auch Architektin Jimena gekommen.
Voilà. Y vamos para el fondo.
Gracias.
* Lachen *
Cómo andan?
- Cómo andan? - Hola, Mauricio.
Hola.
- Cómo andan? Muy bien. Permiso.
Noch einmal wollen sie die Baupläne
durchgehen und Änderungen vornehmen.
Als gelernter Bauschreiner
mit jahrelanger Erfahrung
hat Ruedi klare Vorstellungen.
Claro, cámarasen cada quiebre.
Ein Projekt führen ...
Ich hatte die Bauleitung im Kosovo
für Brücken, Strassen, Häuserbauten.
Das bringt sicher etwas.
Auch mit den Ausstellungen:
Dort hat man schon
die Dinge im Detail gesehen,
wie es gemacht wird,
mit allem Drum und Dran.
Das kommt mir sicher zugute.
Ich muss aber daran denken,
dass wir nicht in der Schweiz sind.
Man darf den südamerikanischen Touch
nicht vergessen.
Sie machen die Dinge anders
und sicher auch gut.
Es ist manchmal eine Gratwanderung.
Wir sind dort die Fremden.
Du kannst nicht erwarten,
dass es so geht.
Man muss sich etwas anpassen.
Wenn du das nicht
akzeptieren kannst, gehst du kaputt.
Wir können nicht hin und sagen:
"Da sind wir.
Wir sind d i e Schweizer."
"Das muss so laufen.
Wir brauchen das Material."
Es ist nicht,
wie wir uns das hier gewohnt sind.
Aber wenn ich in Südamerika
dann mal eine gerade 3-m-Latte habe,
dann mache ich ein Kreuz
an die Decke.
Uh, ist das kalt! Qué frío!
Es ist Winter in Uruguay, als Susanne
im August 2019 auch ankommt.
Die Sonne scheint und es ist kalt.
Willkommen.
Es freut mich, dass du hier bist.
Danke. Gleichfalls.
Und deine Katze.
- Ja, meine Katze.
Ihr ist auch kalt.
Herzlich willkommen!
Gemeinsam fahren sie zum Grundstück -
ihrem neuen Daheim.
Jedes Mal,
wenn ich hier durchkomme ...
... finde ich es extrem schön.
Diese Weite und das Unendliche!
Es ist jedes Mal anders.
Man ist dem Himmel etwas näher.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ja, jetzt sind wir gleich da.
Wenn du rüberschaust, siehst du es.
Sieh an!
Susanne sieht zum ersten Mal,
wie Ruedi
auf der Baustelle vorangekommen ist.
Überraschung!
Das ist ja unglaublich.
Moment!
Richtig bewusst wurde es mir
wirklich in der letzten Kurve,
als wir dann zum Grundstück fuhren.
Dann hatte ich plötzlich das Gefühl:
"Hey, ich gehe nicht in die Ferien."
"Ich wandere jetzt aus.
Das wird mein neues Zuhause."
Ich glaube, das war die Müdigkeit,
die Reise, das ganze Drum und Dran.
Und dann macht es wusch.
Freunde - zwei ausgewanderte
Zürcher - erwarten sie.
Schön.
- Geht's dir gut?
Sehr.
- Hallo.
Bist du so müde? So traurig?
- Nein, gar nicht traurig.
Einfach überwältigt von allem.
Hast du gesehen, was dein Mann ...
Nein, du hast noch nichts gesehen.
Komm!
Hm?
Ja, ist gut.
- Willst du dein neues Heim sehen?
Ja, gerne.
Und wir müssen
unsere Katze rauslassen.
Das ist unser Container.
Hm?
- Unser Container.
Das ist es also,
ihr provisorisches Zuhause:
ein gelber Wohncontainer.
Ah, cool.
Aber kalt. Uh!
Kalt?
- Kalt.
Ich gebe dir etwas Wärme.
So.
22.
Schön, schön.
Du musst dich
an die Sonnenuntergänge gewöhnen.
Die hast du meistens.
- Die hast du mir auch geschickt.
* Lockere Musik *
Tatamagouche
in der Provinz Nova Scotia
ist ein beliebter Ausflugsort.
Das Balmoral Motel der Almeidas
ist bestens gelegen -
direkt an der Hauptstrasse.
Als die Pandemie ausbrach, erlitt
das Geschäft einen herben Dämpfer.
Die Almeidas nutzten die Zeit
während des Lockdowns
und renovierten den Frühstücksraum
des Motels komplett.
Im Sommer
eröffneten sie darin ein Café.
Je pense qu'il y a. Une seconde.
Ein Café
nicht nur für die Gäste ihres Motels,
sondern für alle.
Machst du mir schnell ... Bea?
Und das läuft wie geschmiert.
Bea, kannst du mir die
bitte in die Kühle bringen?
Dann zerlaufen sie weniger,
habe ich gemerkt.
Eigentlich glaubten die Almeidas, das
Café nebenbei betreiben zu können.
Doch weit gefehlt.
Die Schweizer
wurden regelrecht überrannt.
Besonders an den Wochenenden
zum Brunch ist die Hölle los.
(Englisch)
Dazu kommt, dass die Almeidas
hohe Ansprüche haben.
Ob Süsses oder Salziges - bei ihnen
ist alles frisch zubereitet.
Wie gesagt, wir versuchen ...
... so viel wie möglich
vorzubereiten.
Wir sind immer dran -
auch gedanklich.
Ich denke das manchmal
in der Nacht noch durch,
wie ich das
noch einfacher machen könnte.
Die Rösti ist z.B.
einfach unser Knackpunkt.
Die braucht einfach so lange,
bis sie fertig ist.
Es gibt keine Möglichkeit,
sie vorzubereiten.
Man muss sie frisch machen.
Wir haben gewisse Dinge verändert.
Wir machen die Kartoffeln woanders
und haben dadurch mehr Platz.
Wir sind immer etwas am Adjustieren,
ja.
Was there nobody there?
Die Almeidas
stockten ihr Personal auf.
Doch in diesen ersten Wochen
seit der Eröffnung
funktionieren die Abläufe
noch nicht optimal.
Sie sind zufrieden mit dem Essen,
aber die Wartezeit ...
... ist etwas lange.
Wir haben erst vor ein paar Wochen
geöffnet.
Wir müssen das etwas rausfinden.
Ich wollte nicht fünf
oder acht Serviertöchter einstellen
und dann wieder
vier entlassen müssen.
Das ist auch nicht angenehm.
Also startete ich lieber
etwas langsam.
Aber wir brauchen mehr Leute.
Aber es ist schwierig,
gutes Personal zu finden.
Mami, mein Fuss tut weh.
- Du kannst hier nicht durchgehen.
Du kannst hier nicht durch.
Geh da raus!
Die Almeidas sind ausgewandert
in der Hoffnung,
ihr Leben ruhiger angehen zu können
und mehr Zeit für die Kinder
zu haben.
Gehen wir zurück in die Schweiz -
als die Familie
zu ihrem Kanada-Abenteuer aufbrach.
* Melancholische Musik *
Noch einmal die Oma umarmen.
Ich habe euch lieb.
- Danke, gleichfalls.
Viel Glück!
- Danke.
(Portugiesisch)
Tschau. Viel Glück!
Tschüss. Danke schön.
* Melancholische Musik *
Es war mega traurig,
weil wir uns von allen verabschieden
mussten, die wir kannten.
Ich fand das mega traurig.
Ich fand es schlimm, weil es
ein mega schlimmer Abschied war.
Der richtige Abschied
kam erst viel später.
Ich glaube im Winter, da war es ...
Da ging es mir eine Weile
nicht so gut.
Ich vermisse die Menschen
wahnsinnig.
Das ist unvorstellbar.
Das ist das,
was ich bei der Auswanderung
am meisten unterschätzt habe.
Während ihrer ersten Kanadaferien
vor gut drei Jahren
haben die Almeidas
diesen ehemaligen Bauernhof entdeckt
und gleich gekauft.
Eins, zwei ...
... drei ...
- Es sind nur drei.
Nein,
es hat noch eines in der Mitte.
Ja, komm.
- Nein, dableiben!
Komm, wir gehen. Jungs, einsteigen!
Mit dem Auto dauert es
eine Viertelstunde nach Tatamagouche.
Heute haben Robin, Sophie und André
ihren ersten Schultag.
Hast du die Unterlagen?
- Ja.
Morning.
- Willkommen.
Willkommen. Thank you.
Schulleiter Bryan Holmes
erwartet die Familie schon.
Fine. Thank you.
- Come on in.
Morning, Josef.
- Morning.
So, Robin?
- This is Robin, yes.
André?
- Yes.
And Sophie.
Willkommen.
Follow me!
Robin.
Der achtjährige Robin
versteht kaum ein Wort.
Schau mal!
- "Herzlich willkommen!"
Genau.
Robin, this is Miss Mac.
Nice to meet you.
- Okay?
You can stay here for the moment.
I'm gonna take everybody over here.
- "Miss" heisst "Frau".
Und "Mac" ist der Name.
- Ich weiss.
Und André ist gleich gegenüber.
Schau, dort drüben!
Ich konnte noch fast kein Wort.
Nur "Hello!" und "How are you?".
Das war alles, das ich sagen konnte.
Und dann nach ein, zwei Wochen
konnte ich ein paar Wörter mehr.
Gehen wir schnell hinauf zu Sophie
und schauen, ob alles gut ist!
Hi. Findest du dich zurecht?
- Ja. - Okay.
Ja, ist gut.
Als Mami und Papi
schnell schauen kamen,
war mir das voll peinlich.
Alle waren so klein ...
Also, nicht klein, einfach Kinder.
Und dann zwei Eltern dort.
Ich wollte einfach,
dass sie mich alleine lassen,
weil ich es besser mache, wenn sie
mir nicht über die Schulter schauen.
Aber ja, es ging dann schon.
Während die Kinder
die Schule besuchen,
treffen Beatrice und Josef
den Vorbesitzer des Motels.
Das Motel hat 18 Zimmer,
gut dreimal so viel
wie ihr Bed and Breakfast,
das sie der Schweiz betrieben haben.
Wir haben es ja schon mal gesehen.
Das ist nicht neu.
Aber man muss dann schon
noch einiges machen.
Viel Potenzial.
- Sagen wir es mal so.
Schön gesagt.
Schatz, es ist kein Hilton!
Die Almeidas haben das Motel
samt Inventar gekauft.
Das war schon länger
nicht mehr in Betrieb.
Man muss einiges ersetzen.
Auch der Gasanzünder
war im Kaufpreis inbegriffen.
Der funktioniert eben nicht richtig.
Doch, doch, er funktioniert.
Es war mega streng.
Ein alter Knochen.
Welcher ist es jetzt?
Verstehst du das Problem?
Ah, genau.
Du meine Güte! One moment.
Ja, man kommt einfach.
Das ist
auch wieder Schweizer Denken:
Alles muss laufen,
alles muss sauber
und alles auf Vordermann sein.
Hier haben sie
eine andere Philosophie.
Für sie
muss es einfach funktionieren.
Ein bisschen.
Und günstig sein.
- Ja.
Nein, ich dachte nicht,
dass ich irgendwelchen ...
... Schrott gekauft hätte.
Wir hatten es schon angeschaut.
Vor dem Kauf machten wir auch
Bewertungen für die Liegenschaft.
Wir hatten uns
schon auch abgesichert.
Ein Vorteil gegenüber der Schweiz
ist:
Almeidas haben hier eine Angestellte.
Ich bin mega froh.
I'm very happy to have you.
Es ist ein Glücksfall,
dass wir sie haben.
Sie weiss schon, wie es läuft,
und ich muss nicht selber putzen.
Auch wenn noch nicht alles
perfekt ist:
Das Balmoral
ist bestens gebucht.
Ein exquisites Frühstück
für die Motelgäste
liegt den Almeidas am Herzen.
Beatrice ist gelernte Köchin.
Während der Sommerferien
helfen die Kinder mit.
Trotz Hochsaison renoviert
die Familie die Gästezimmer komplett.
Nirgends anstossen.
Nirgends anstossen, Sophie!
Drücke es ganz fest zusammen!
So.
Alle 18 Zimmer
sollen neu eingerichtet werden.
Altes muss Neuem Platz machen.
Über 100 Möbelstücke
zum selber Zusammenbauen
haben sie sich liefern lassen.
Siehst du, was für einer das ist?
Die Nummer 1 vom Dreier.
Ja, wir haben viel gemacht.
Wir haben sehr viel gemacht.
Der Unterschied ist riesig.
Leute, die das Gebäude kennen -
von vor 15 Jahren oder so,
als es noch als Restaurant
funktionierte -,
flippen beinahe aus.
Sie kommen herein
und können kaum glauben,
wie viel wir verändert haben.
Das gibt uns recht.
Wir haben es richtig gemacht.
Wir haben die richtige Mischung
zwischen machen und lassen gefunden.
* Lockere Musik *
Wenige Tage
nach der Schlüsselübergabe
feiern die Schweizer Eröffnung.
Vogelscheisse.
Das wird noch geputzt.
Ach ja, unsere Putzszene!
Das Ehepaar Kunz hat es gewagt:
Die einstigen Angestellten
sind Unternehmer geworden.
Ja, genau, so macht man es, oder?
Das ist schon klar.
Schatz, es ist gut.
Dort musst du nichts mehr machen.
Wieso? Willst du mir sagen ...
Hast du schon alle Stühle geputzt?
Ja. Nein, die Stühle nicht.
Doch, alles.
Schatz, können wir öffnen? Schatz?
Nein, ehrlich! Du kannst ja noch ...
Nimm doch alles weg!
- Ja.
Was wegnehmen?
- Dort habe ich geputzt.
Nein, eben nicht richtig.
Du hast nur darübergewischt.
Ja, ist gut.
- Gut, du kannst langsam kommen.
So nervös
war Sacha schon lange nicht mehr.
Langsam!
Ja, es ist gut.
Du musst den Daumen draufhalten.
- Wo?
Du musst die Luft ...
Bei der Öffnung.
Hier? Meinst du hier?
- Ja.
Ah, damit er ansaugt!
- Genau.
Es geht nicht.
- Doch, doch.
Hi!
- Hallo!
Einmal Pommes mit Mayonnaise!
- Gerne.
Danke schön!
Die ersten eigenen Pommes -
neun Monate,
nachdem die Auswanderer den Imbiss
in den Ferien entdeckt hatten.
Guten Appetit!
- Danke!
Die Hafenterrasse
füllt sich immer mehr.
Was sagte sie? Röstzwiebeln?
Röstzwiebeln oder frische Zwiebeln?
Röstzwiebeln, super.
So, guten Appetit!
Besser geht es nicht.
Abendstimmung am Kutterhafen.
10 Std. standen Brigitte und Sacha
am Eröffnungstag hinter dem Grill.
Noch aber ist nicht Schluss:
Kassensturz.
662 Euro haben sie eingenommen.
Ja, gut gearbeitet.
Wir wissen,
was man hier im Jahr macht,
was man in diesen acht Monaten
erreichen kann.
Das ist kein schlechter Betrag.
Also, wir können sicher davon leben,
das ist so.
Das ist nicht ...
Das müssen wir nicht leugnen.
Wegen Corona
wird es leider etwas enger,
aber wir sind guten Mutes
und schauen zuversichtlich voraus.
Jetzt muss Sacha nur noch
das Öl der Fritteuse ersetzen.
Doch irgendetwas
stimmt nicht mit dem Auslauf.
Anfänger.
Es ist komisch,
dass es nicht herauskommt.
Was machst du?
Bist du wahnsinnig?
Nein, Schatz!
- Es kommt nicht heraus.
Und? Bist du schon weiter?
"Bist du schon weiter?", ja.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Das war
ein richtiges Anfängerproblem.
Mittlerweile mache ich den
Fritteusenwechsel sogar am Sonntag,
wenn es Leute hat.
Heute ohne Probleme.
Im Herbst, wenn
die alljährlichen Sturmtiefs kommen,
ist die Saison vorbei.
Dann ist es Zeit,
den "Küsten-Imbiss"
in die Winterpause zu entlassen.
Heute wollen die Kunzens
den Wagen nach Padingbüttel fahren.
Das ist übel. Aber sag du mir:
Wie kam der hierher?
Die sind so porös.
Die Reifen
sind nicht mehr fahrtauglich.
Der auch.
Ja, ich ...
Wir wussten ja, wie alt er war.
Das war uns bewusst, aber ...
Ja,
vielleicht wäre es schön gewesen,
wenn wir ein paar Sachen
im Voraus gewusst hätten.
Nicht,
dass gewisse Sachen defekt waren,
aber wir hätten es
einfach gerne gewusst.
Es waren Investitionen
von ein paar Tausend Euro.
Aber es war ja nicht irgendwie ...
... viel.
Es waren aber trotzdem Ausgaben,
die nicht geplant waren.
Es ist einfach schade, dass er uns
nicht sagte, was alles defekt war.
Nachbar André
hilft den Schweizern aus der Patsche
und organisiert Ersatzpneus.
Im Schritttempo geht die Fahrt
zum Winterquartier in Padingbüttel.
* Lockere Musik *
Vorsicht!
Es reicht. Gut.
Winterpause? Nichts für Sacha.
Der Jungunternehmer
hat bereits eine neue Idee.
Gefällt es Ihnen?
- Ja.
Er möchte sich einen zweiten,
kleineren Wagen anschaffen.
So könnte er
auch in der kalten Jahreszeit
Pommes und Würste verkaufen.
Wie steht es heute, ein Jahr danach,
um Sachas Grillunternehmen?
Tschüss!
Dazu später.
Sonnenschein, aber nur 8 °C.
Die erste Nacht im Container
ist vorüber.
Die Küche ist zu klein.
- Wieso?
Für all das, was wir mitgenommen
haben und das du gekriegt hast.
Nein, nein, es ist super.
Bis der erste Bungalow steht, wohnen
Susanne und Ruedi auf knapp 14 m2.
So, jetzt hat es
schon viel mehr Platz.
Ja, ja.
Als ich am Morgen aufstand,
wollte ich bereits Sachen umstellen.
Ich habe den Junggesellenhaushalt
meines Mannes auf den Kopf gestellt.
Das Katzenfutter und so
kann man ins Badezimmer stellen.
Das muss nicht in der Küche sein.
Im Badezimmer hat es noch Platz.
Das kann man, ja.
Solange du mir das Bier
im Kühlschrank lässt.
Ja, das lasse ich im Kühlschrank.
Vom Emmental
in die südamerikanische Pampa.
Auch die Katze Ghöri
ist mit ausgewandert.
Hier darunter darfst du nicht.
Da kann ich dich nicht hervorholen.
Nein, nicht hier darunter.
Komm, gehen wir rein!
Im Menschenalter
wäre unsere Katze bereits 55-jährig.
Mit 55 Jahren von einem ganz ...
... oder von einem sicheren Ort,
den man schon so lange kennt,
an einen ganz anderen Ort zu gehen,
ist schon stressig für ihn.
Als ich es hörte,
wurde es mir auch gerade bewusst:
Wir sind auch schon fast so alt
und sind an einem neuen Ort.
Die Katze hat sich aber
schneller daran gewöhnt als wir.
Es sind 100 Sachen,
die du neu lernen musst.
Der Alltag ist anders.
Deshalb denke ich, fühlte sich die
Katze schneller zu Hause als ich.
Der Schachtring aus Beton ist
für den neuen Brunnen ihrer Posada.
Kannst du drei dieser Hölzer
bringen?
Die Ferienlodge
ist nicht ihr erstes Projekt.
Wohin?
Eines hier ...
Hier?
... und eines vorne in der Mitte.
Schon ihr Haus im Emmental
haben die beiden eigenhändig gebaut.
Der Brunnen
soll künftig fünf Bungalows,
ein Restaurant sowie den Swimmingpool
mit Wasser versorgen.
Ich bin der Hilfsarbeiter.
Ich stehe da und schaue,
dass er es richtig macht.
Brauchst du dieses Klebeband noch
oder nimmst du neues?
Du kannst es
oben im Container holen.
Wenn du hereinkommst, halbrechts,
etwa in der Mitte rechts, hat es.
Dann können wir noch neues nehmen.
Das eigene Grundwasser war ihnen
beim Kauf des Landes wichtig.
Das Projekt, das wir hier haben:
Wir pumpen Grundwasser ab.
Das hat natürlich auch den Vorteil,
dass es uns nichts kostet.
Die Wasserqualität
ist eigentlich gut.
Du kannst hier oben neues nehmen.
Schau,
dass wir hier untendurch gehen!
Kannst du kurz halten?
Von der Krankenpflegerin
zur Hilfsarbeiterin.
Susanne
wird noch manche Gelegenheit haben,
in diese Rolle hineinzuwachsen.
Noch ein bisschen nach vorne.
Gut! Runter!
Es gibt sicher viele Frauen,
die gesagt hätten:
"Weisst du was? Du kannst mich mal."
Vielleicht
war sie manchmal nahe dran.
Nein.
Nein, das kannst du
nicht mit jeder ...
Das kannst du nicht
mit allen Leuten machen.
Ich wollte es ja.
Wir wussten ja, dass wir
praktisch bei null anfangen,
daher ...
Ich finde es ja wirklich cool.
Ich muss dir ein Kränzchen winden.
Du hast dich gut geschlagen.
Im ersten Sommer ihrer Auswanderung
kaufen sich die Althaus' einen Hund:
Che, ein Uruguayischer Cimarrón.
Und später kommt
die zugelaufene Hundedame Mini dazu.
Bald schon
ist der erste Bungalow fertig gebaut.
In diesen
wollen die Althaus' selber einziehen,
endlich raus aus dem Container.
Was nicht passt,
wird passend gemacht.
Seit Tagen
ist die 53-Jährige am Isolieren -
doppelwandig.
Ja, ja, das ist so Kleinarbeit.
Mittlerweile ist das Isolieren
nicht mehr das Schlimmste für mich.
Jetzt weiss ich, wie man das macht.
Feierabend.
Gut 10 Std. hat Ruedi
auf der Baustelle geschuftet.
Susanne bereitet bereits
das Abendessen vor.
Nach 30 Jahren Beziehung
stürzten sich die beiden nochmals
in ein gemeinsames Abenteuer ...
... und scheinen sich so nah,
wie schon lange nicht mehr.
Guten Appetit!
- Guten Appetit!
Auf uns?
Auf das Leben.
- Darauf, dass wir hier sind.
Die Leute fragen uns oft,
wie es ist,
wenn wir immer 24 Std. zusammen sind
und so.
Ich finde es mega cool,
dass wir das zusammen machen können.
Nach 30 Jahren Beziehung
gibt es schon die einen
oder anderen Unstimmigkeiten.
Aber es sind nicht
die grossen Sachen.
Es sind die kleinen Sachen,
die dazugehören.
Da streitet man sich hin und wieder
ein bisschen.
So soll es auch sein.
Das Schöne für mich ist:
Unsere Beziehung stimmt.
Abschied in Kanada.
Beatrice fliegt in die Schweiz.
Zum allerersten Mal verlässt die
Mutter die Familie für längere Zeit.
Sie fliegt in die alte Heimat,
um Guetzli für Weihnachtsmärkte
zu backen.
Viel Spass!
- Danke schön!
Schaut gut auf euch!
Das machen wir.
- Wir sind stolz auf dich.
Das Schweizer Guetzligeschäft ist
das zweite Standbein der Almeidas.
Sie kommt ja bald wieder.
In zwei Monaten ist sie wieder hier.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ich vermisse Bea bereits jetzt sehr.
Es sind erst fünf Minuten vergangen.
Ja ...
... es ist wie mit vielem:
Man beschliesst etwas im Voraus,
setzt sich etwas in den Kopf
und macht es dann einfach.
Die Realität ist dann
im Moment selber manchmal halt ...
... ein bisschen anders,
ein bisschen schwieriger.
Wenn du dann dort bist, sagst du:
"2 1/2 Monate sind ja mega viel!"
"So lange getrennt von der Familie,
von den Kindern und von Jose."
Das ist schon nicht nichts.
Während die Mutter in der Schweiz
wochenlang Guetzli bäckt,
schaut Josef
für das Motel und die Kinder.
"Trick or treat" -
"Süsses oder Saures".
Es ist Halloween.
Jetzt kann Halloween kommen.
Die nächsten Stunden
ziehen Almeidas Kinder mit ihren
Freunden durch die Nachbarschaft.
Sophie!
Komm herein! Genug Theater!
Die Zeit ohne Beatrice
ist für Josef
immer wieder nervenaufreibend.
Nein, dann gehst du irgendwohin.
Mir reicht es jetzt.
Genug Theater.
Ich muss auch ein paar Dinge
erledigen, Sophie.
Das Kindergartengetue
kannst du später wieder machen.
Ausgerechnet jetzt
hat sich der elfjährige André
auch noch den Arm gebrochen.
Wegen dieser Unterschrift
hast du so blöd getan.
Du hast wegen dieser Unterschrift
geschrien.
So!
Genau. So.
Es kam alles auf einmal:
das mit Andrés Armbruch und dann ...
Ja ...
Und immer wieder
all diese Freunde ...
Ehrlich gesagt, ist das schon
ein bisschen anstrengend.
Auf der anderen Seite
gönne ich es den Kindern sehr,
dass sie so viele tolle Leute
um sich haben.
Dann die Aufgaben,
du musst die Leute führen,
die Gäste bewirten.
Ja, es ist einfach viel auf einmal.
Und dennoch:
Man wächst in der Aufgabe.
Noch wenige Minuten.
Robin, du kannst Nintendo spielen,
wenn du willst.
Das stört mich nicht.
- Yes!
Bald ist Beatrice wieder da.
Für Josef vielleicht
die längsten Minuten seines Lebens.
Seit 23 Jahren
war er nie mehr als drei Tage
von seiner Liebsten getrennt.
Sie hat sich Spaghetti und Poulet
gewünscht.
Mit dem Poulet
macht sie es mir einfach.
Das ist schon vorbereitet.
Spaghetti und eine Sauce.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ich sah, wie er hüpfte.
Lustig.
Mami!
- Hallo!
Oh, ist das schön!
Hoi!
- Hoi!
Diese vielen Kinder.
Ah, das war verdammt schön!
Am Tag vor ihrer Rückkehr liess Papa
uns 2 oder 3 Std. aufräumen,
damit alles perfekt war.
Als sie dann endlich hier war,
haben wir gegessen.
Ja, es war ein ziemlich schöner Tag.
Die Wiedersehensfreude war gross.
Es ist unbeschreiblich.
Nach einer so langen Trennung
schätzt man einander ganz anders.
Man vermisst viele Sachen,
die einem im Alltag nicht auffallen.
Wenn man aber so lange getrennt ist,
denkt man schon:
"Das ist schon speziell.
Eigentlich haben wir es gut."
Oder? Wir passen schon zusammen.
Schon ein bisschen verliebt, ja.
- Ein bisschen verliebt?
Ja.
* Ruhige Musik *
Zurück in ihrer neuen Heimat Uruguay.
Susanne und Ruedi sind retour
aus ihren Schweizer Ferien.
Einige Monate schon lebt das Ehepaar
nicht mehr im Container,
sondern im Bungalow.
Das Haus hat zwei Schlafzimmer,
eine kleine Küche und ein Wohnzimmer.
Nein, den verschieben wir
nicht mehr, der bleibt dort drin.
Schon fast fertig ist auch das
Restaurant der Posada Casa Vieja.
Damit kommen Susanne und Ruedi
ihrem Traum einer Ferienlodge
ein grosses Stück näher.
Das wollen sie heute
mit einem Essen feiern.
Nur noch schnell
die Bodenplatten ausfugen.
Freund Juan und seine Frau Andrea
aus Colonia
unterstützen die Posada-Besitzer.
Es ist ein Einrichten
und Austesten ...
... denn endlich ist das Mobiliar
für das Restaurant eingetroffen.
Und auch die Küche ist eingebaut.
Ja, jetzt teste ich erst einmal
den Backofen.
Ich bin gespannt ...
Vielleicht ist es riskant, etwas für
ein Fest zum ersten Mal zu testen.
Und wenn Herr Haus den Strom wieder
anschliesst, kann ich auch backen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Wegen der etwas schwierigen
aktuellen Coronasituation
mache ich eine Käseplatte,
eine Käse- und Fleischplatte.
Ein Essen, zu dem man sich
nicht hinsetzen muss.
Man kann sich verteilen
und drinnen oder draussen sein.
Kannst du den Schalter drücken?
Dort drüben.
Ist die Birne defekt?
Ich schalte aus.
Ja, ja, ja.
In Sachen Bauen ist Herr Haus schon
ein bisschen ein Perfektionist.
Bevor die Gäste eintrudeln,
macht sich Susanne auf
in den nahe gelegenen Käseladen:
den "Edelweiss".
Im südlichen Uruguay
hatten sich um 1860
Hunderte Schweizer niedergelassen.
Schweizer Käse ist hier deshalb
immer noch Kulturgut.
* Beschwingte Ländlermusik *
Das "Edelweiss" hat ein kleines,
aber ausgesuchtes Angebot.
Juan José Rabazas Geschäft
sind Sbrinz, Emmentaler und Würste -
alles made in Uruguay.
* Fröhliche Jodelmusik *
* Ruhige Musik *
Zurück in der Posada Casa Vieja:
Ches Wachinstinkt ist geweckt,
die Gäste sind da.
Autostopp! Autostopp!
Alex, die Auswanderungsberaterin,
kommt als Erste.
Danach der Holzhändler
und seine Familie.
Alex' Dienste als Beraterin
brauchen die Auswanderer nicht mehr.
Mit Dornen,
aber frisch gepflückt ...
... und mit Tierchen.
- Mit Tierchen.
Sie ist eine wichtige Freundin
geworden.
Ah, claro!
Ja, deine Duschwanne.
Wir machen hier alles all inclusive.
* Beschwingte Musik *
In einem Jahr
streichen wir nochmals.
Das Restaurant ist fertig.
Eine wichtige Etappe
ist geschafft ...
... und noch viele werden folgen.
Stück für Stück
bauen sich die Althaus' eigenhändig
ihr kleines Paradies.
* Lockere Musik *
Am Dorumer Kutterhafen
geniessen Brigitte und Sacha Kunz
ihren Promistatus.
Vielen Dank!
Viele Schweizer verbringen -
nicht zuletzt wegen Corona -
ihre Ferien an der Nordsee.
Das ist die zweite und Pommes.
- Vielen Dank!
Guten Appetit!
- Guten Appetit!
Danke!
- Bitte schön!
Die Coronapandemie hat das Leben
der Deutschland-Auswanderer
ziemlich durcheinandergebracht.
Das Gute ist:
Es gibt keinen Zwist mehr
wegen der Sauberkeit von Stühlen
und Tischen.
Die sind weggepackt.
Social distancing.
Die Gäste essen stehend
oder auf dem Deich.
Sechs lange Wochen
war der "Küsten-Imbiss"
während des Lockdowns geschlossen.
Es war natürlich nicht schön.
Wir eröffneten am 22. März oder so.
Wir hatten alles eingekauft.
Am Abend kam die Meldung,
alles wieder dichtzumachen.
Wir mussten viel wegschmeissen,
verschenken oder wie auch immer.
Deshalb hatten wir in dieser Zeit
auch null Einkommen.
Es war schon ...
Ich hatte sicher Existenzängste -
im Sinne von: "Wie geht es weiter?"
"Können wir bzw. wann können wir
wieder aufmachen?"
Unsere Saison ist kurz.
Es hätte sich ja den ganzen Sommer
durchziehen können.
Man wusste es nicht.
Dann stellt sich die Frage,
wie man durch den Winter kommt.
Aber wir hatten ja Glück und
konnten im Mai wieder aufmachen.
Aber das, was wir verloren haben,
holen wir nicht mehr auf.
Das ganze Ostergeschäft
ging verloren.
Und ja, das ist viel Geld,
das weg ist - leider.
Umso grösser die Freude
und das Engagement,
als die beiden den Grill
wieder anwerfen durften.
Die Currywurst! Bitte schön.
Guten Appetit!
- Danke.
Tschüss!
- Tschüss! Danke!
Nein, es ist immer noch gleich.
Es macht immer noch Spass.
Es ist immer noch motivierend,
am Morgen arbeiten zu gehen.
Für mich
ist es eigentlich der Traum,
der in Erfüllung ging.
Dementsprechend
fühle ich mich hier wohl.
Ich gebe alles
und ich gebe Gas für diesen Wagen,
damit es funktioniert
und dass es auch ...
... dementsprechend
für die Kunden rüberkommt.
Ich glaube,
wir sind auf dem richtigen Weg.
Wir fühlen uns absolut wohl.
Ja, wirklich.
Auch die Kinder.
Ja, wir haben uns supergut
und sehr schnell eingelebt.
Kunzens fühlen sich wohl
und ihr Clan wird immer grösser.
* Bellen *
Die mit ausgewanderte Roxy
ist hochschwanger.
Ihr Bauch sieht schon komisch aus.
Es bewegt sich immer irgendetwas.
Das sind die Jungen.
- Ach so?
Oder das Atmen.
Das, was du jetzt siehst,
ist das Atmen.
Weisst du wie süss, wenn sie
ihre Babys jetzt bekommen würde?
Wie viele Babys es wohl sein werden?
Die Oma bastelt mit den Kindern
ein Geburtsnest.
Ich würde es mal so sagen:
Ich habe hier meine Ruhe gefunden.
Auch,
wenn es natürlich nicht so aussieht.
Aber die innere Ruhe
habe ich hier gefunden.
Ich bin innerlich viel ruhiger.
Wenn ich mich nerve, nehme ich
den Hund und gehe spazieren.
Das ist ideal.
Die Rentnerin
ist mit über 70 Jahren ausgewandert.
Sie ist da, wenn Tochter
und Schwiegersohn am Grill stehen,
hilft bei den Hausaufgaben der Enkel
und kümmert sich schon bald
um einen Wurf Katzenbabys.
Noemi hatte anfänglich Mühe
in der neuen Heimat.
Doch etwas Wichtiges hat sie gelernt:
zu sich selbst stehen.
Zu Beginn war es nicht einfach,
Freunde zu finden.
Am Anfang war ich wirklich ruhig
und sprach mit niemandem.
Jetzt spreche ich.
Es ist wegen der Sprache und so.
Ich spreche
nicht so gerne Hochdeutsch.
Aber ich begann, mich zu öffnen.
Da kamen sie auch auf mich zu -
durch das Sprechen, würde ich sagen.
Wenn ich nichts sage,
wissen sie auch nichts von mir.
Machst du dort?
Ich mache hier.
Oma Susanne hat einen guten Zugang
zu den Zwillingen.
Ja, ich denke, sie sind angekommen.
Sie hatten nie - zumindest nicht,
dass ich wüsste ...
Oder?
- Was?
Ihr hattet nie Probleme
mit Schulkameraden oder so.
Nein, gar nicht.
Das war das Schöne: Beide wurden
in der Klasse voll aufgenommen.
Ich denke, das ist sehr wichtig.
Es ist natürlich spannend,
wenn plötzlich Schweizer
in der Klasse sind.
Bitte?
- Es ist spannend für sie,
Schweizer in der Klasse zu haben.
- Das stimmt.
Es macht auch sehr Spass,
auch mit der Klasse.
Was hier auch sehr schön ist,
ist, mit Freunden draussen zu sein.
Zurück an den Kutterhafen.
Kunzens sind oftmals die Letzten,
die ihre Bude schliessen.
Zweimal? Ja.
Guten Appetit!
Mein Motto war immer:
Wir lassen an diesem Wagen
niemanden verhungern.
Deshalb schliessen wir, wenn es
wirklich keine Leute mehr hat.
Das Wetter ist gut.
Heute ist wieder ein Traumtag.
Warum sollte ich die Klappe bereits
um 19 oder 20 Uhr schliessen?
Ich lasse sie offen und nehme mit,
was ich noch kann.
* Ruhige Musik *
Guten Appetit
und einen schönen Abend!
Unsere Work-Life-Balance
sind wir noch am Suchen.
Aber diese Saison
ist es viel besser.
Ich muss oder möchte
einen Tag zu Hause bleiben.
Dann ist eine Angestellte hier.
Jetzt, zwischen den Ferien,
kommt sowieso die Zeit,
in der nicht mehr so viel läuft.
Dann bin ich sowieso mehr zu Hause.
Dann ist hauptsächlich er hier.
Ja, daher ...
Ich denke,
es wird jedes Jahr besser.
Und neu steht ja auch Sohn Kevin
hinter dem Grill.
Gut.
Damit Althaus' ihren einzigen
bisher fertiggestellten Bungalow
vermieten könnten,
ziehen sie erneut in den Container.
So!
Dieser ist
nicht mehr ganz so gut in Schuss.
Da ist ein Bienennest.
Hast du das gesehen, Schatz?
Ja, ja.
Mir wäre es lieber, sie würden sonst
irgendwo Honig fabrizieren.
Während der ersten Monate in Uruguay
lebten die beiden im Container.
Die Enge und die Feuchtigkeit im
Winter schlugen Susanne aufs Gemüt.
Willst du nicht Magnete benutzen?
- Nein. Die fallen nicht runter.
Also gut!
Ja, die Frau Hüsi hatte vor
einem Jahr ihren Container-Koller,
das stimmt.
Aber ich denke,
wir geben ihr eine zweite Chance.
Wenn der Container anders aussieht,
kann sie versuchen,
ob das Leben im Container während
des Sommers - nicht im Winter -
nicht etwas für sie wäre. Ich denke,
das wird sie schon schaffen.
Nein, das mit dem Container-Koller
ist nicht ...
Klar hatte es sich angebahnt,
aber es war eine kurze Zeit.
Nein, die Situation war anders:
Vor einem Jahr hattest du hier
einen Container und fertig.
Hier musstest du leben,
duschen und sein.
Wenn es draussen regnete
und stürmte,
war es hier drin
halt eben auch feucht.
Und das ist schon ...
Ja, das ist nicht gerade jedermanns
oder jederfraus Sache.
Das hier?
Das können wir brauchen als ...
Das befestigen wir dann wieder.
- Ja.
Ich sagte nicht,
dass wir es nicht wieder befestigen.
Ich nehme es nur weg.
Eine richtige Umzugskiste, was?
Ja, ja.
Oje, wir hätten
auch aussenrum gehen können.
Im Bungalow
darf es ein wenig gemütlicher sein.
Dafür soll ein neuer Sessel sorgen.
Auf den Tisch?
- Nein, warte, auf den Boden.
Auf den Boden ist besser.
Jetzt wird es warm.
- Mhm.
Susanne ist eine geübte Fotografin.
Diese Bilder
samt neuem roten Fauteuil
müssen besonders attraktiv werden.
Sie sollen auf der Homepage
für den Bungalow werben.
* Klicken *
Es ist so ...
Das mit der Internetseite sitzt wie
ein kleiner Teufel in meinem Kopf,
weil ich diese Fotos
schon lange hätte machen sollen.
Durch die ganze Coronasituation ...
Ich kann nicht sagen,
wir hätten es verzögert,
aber ich weiss ja nicht,
wann diese Gäste kommen.
Ich hoffe schon, dass wir ...
Unser Ziel ist,
es Anfang Dezember zu eröffnen.
Doch wann erste Touristen ihre Ferien
im Bungalow verbringen werden,
ist ungewiss.
Wegen der Pandemie hält Uruguay
seit März die Grenzen geschlossen.
Der Tourismus
ist völlig eingebrochen.
Die Chance, etwas Neues zu machen,
haben wir wahrgenommen.
Dass sich das jetzt
alles anders entwickelt hat
oder in Entwicklung ist, konnte ja
niemand voraussagen, aber ...
... dann darf man nie
etwas anderes machen als das,
was man schon vorher gemacht hat,
denn es kann ja immer
irgendetwas entstehen,
das alles auf den Kopf stellt.
Und jetzt haben wir eine Situation,
die wirklich alles
auf den Kopf gestellt hat.
Jetzt schauen wir, dass wir
das Beste daraus machen können.
Che ist mittlerweile ein Teenie
mit vielen Flausen geworden.
* Bellen *
* Blöken *
Besonders die Schafe des Nachbarn
haben es ihm angetan.
Damit Che nicht die Herde aufmischt,
musste Ruedi
einen elektrischen Zaun spannen,
einen Viehhüter.
Doch, sieht gut aus. Es läuft.
Unsere Ausgabe betreffend.
Ja, der geht auch.
Das Teil funktioniert. Das ist gut!
Ohne das ... Ja, es läuft.
Ohne diese zwei Racker
hätte ich 500 Dollar sparen können.
Aber auch das gehört dazu. Gut!
Bisher hatte Ruedi nur Ausgaben.
Doch er nimmt es
mit südländischer Gelassenheit.
Wenn du reich werden willst,
ist Uruguay nicht unbedingt
die richtige Destination.
Aber um zu leben
und Träume erfüllen zu können,
ist es sicher
eine der besseren Destinationen,
die du auswählen kannst.
Ja, darum sind wir ja auch hier.
Du musst dir Träume erfüllen können.
Mit Geld alleine
hast du nicht gelebt.
Das ist die Einstellung
von Frau Hüsi und mir.
Orangen, Mandarinen,
Zitronen und Dutzende Pinien
haben die Althaus auf
ihrem riesigen Gelände angepflanzt.
Jetzt gehe ich mit Kermit
die Blumen giessen.
Ich wäre gerne mal Bauer
oder Bäuerin geworden
und hätte einen Traktor
fahren wollen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ob ich perfekt Traktor fahren kann,
weiss ich nicht,
aber ich kann Kermit fahren.
Träume erfüllen sich manchmal anders,
als man denkt ...
... und manchmal sogar besser,
als man sich erträumt.
* Ruhige Musik *
An den Wochenenden brummt das Café.
Am Vorabend kaufen Beatrice und Josef
jeweils ein -
und zwar in grossen Mengen.
Hast du das Gefühl, das reicht?
Sonst schicken wir morgen
die Kinder nochmals.
Lieber noch einen Sack dazunehmen.
Kartoffeln
müssen wir ganz viele haben.
Und Eier.
Für unser Frühstück von morgen.
Das ist eigentlich das.
Was hast du noch gefunden, Bea?
- Tomaten fürs Frühstück.
Ich würde sie nicht
dort reinquetschen. Lieber hier.
Irgendetwas
hat sie noch geschrieben:
Datteln und noch irgendetwas.
Aber ich habe es vergessen.
Der gute Ruf von Almeidas Eierspeisen
und Süssgebäck
hat sich in der Gegend
schnell verbreitet.
An einem einzigen Wochenende
verarbeitet ihre Küchencrew
über 400 Eier.
* Ruhige Musik *
Selbst während des Lockdowns
durften die Schweizer
das Motel offen halten -
weil die Zimmer
direkt von aussen zugänglich sind.
Trotzdem:
Die Buchungen brachen drastisch ein.
Langsam
kehren die Touristen nun zurück.
Heute ist das Balmoral
sogar ausgebucht.
Ja, es zeigt mir ...
... dass wir profitabel sind.
Aber es sind natürlich
ganz wenige Nächte in diesem Jahr.
Ich glaube,
es ist die zweite oder so.
Und sonst haben wir das ...
Also im letzten Jahr hatten wir das
jeden zweiten, dritten Tag.
Aber man nimmt, was man bekommt.
Ich bin froh.
Baseball ist während Corona
die einzige Sportart,
die in Nova Scotia erlaubt ist.
Beim Training können die Spieler
genügend Abstand halten.
André und Robin
trainieren zweimal in der Woche
bei den Tatamagouche Junior Jays.
Go, go, go!
Gehen wir nach Hause?
- Bye, guys!
See you, guys!
Kein Würstchen?
Zuerst war der Lockdown,
jetzt sind Sommerferien.
Über fünf Monate haben die Kinder
keine Schule mehr besucht.
Endlich können Almeidas
mehr Zeit mit ihnen verbringen.
Das einzig Gute
an den Pandemie-Monaten.
Ja.
Man erlebt einfach immer etwas viel
an einem Tag.
Und ja, es gibt halt schon Tage,
an denen man müde ist.
Man ist auch kribbelig wegen morgen.
Morgen ist ja nochmals so ein Tag.
Ja.
Morgen wird wahrscheinlich
noch schlimmer.
Wir haben ja schon für 9 Uhr
eine Reservation für 15 Personen.
Danach geht es wahrscheinlich
gleich so weiter.
Morgen wird ziemlich busy, ja.
Almeidas geht die Arbeit nie aus.
Morgen müssen auch die Kinder
wieder im Restaurant antraben.
* Ruhige Musik *
Montevideo ist die neue Hauptstadt
unserer Uruguay-Auswanderer.
Hier mündet der gigantische Rio de
la Plata in den Atlantischen Ozean.
Tag für Tag arbeiten Susanne
und Ruedi auf ihrer Baustelle.
Doch sie haben gelernt,
sich kleine Auszeiten zu gönnen.
Ab und an geniessen sie
das Leben der Grossstadt
und verbinden das Nützliche
mit dem Faszinierenden.
Hier finden sie alles,
was sie für ihre Posada brauchen.
61 cm - das ginge auch.
Das wäre mit dem Möbel.
Auf ihrer Einkaufsliste steht ein
Waschbecken für die Gästetoilette.
Da hättest du auch noch
die Möglichkeit, Dinge zu verstauen.
Aber untenrum
könntest du besser putzen.
Sin problema con el piso.
Sie entscheiden sich für die kleinere
und pflegeleichtere Variante.
Kannst du den Schlüssel aus meiner
Hosentasche ziehen und öffnen?
* Lockere Musik *
Ein bisschen runter.
Voilà!
- Ja, ist gut.
Das ist für mich Leben.
Das ist für mich ...
Ja, hier spürst du den Puls,
das Leben.
Hier spürst du eigentlich
die Leute hier.
Das finde ich so schön.
In Uruguay ist das Leben entspannter.
Tranqui, tranqui,
alles schön mit der Ruhe,
wie es in ihrer neuen Heimat heisst.
Willst du dich setzen?
- Kurz reinschauen.
Schön hier, oder?
Hola! Todo bien?
- Gracias!
Gracias!
Obwohl Montevideo
eine Millionenstadt und gross ist,
hat man schon das Gefühl ...
Es ist alles so ein bisschen ...
Die Leute wirken nicht so gestresst
wie in der Schweiz.
Ruhig, gemütlich, praktisch.
Sie machen ihre Sachen,
aber sie gehen sie ruhiger an.
Nicht diese Hektik.
Wunderschön!
Montevideos Gastronomie ist auch
Inspiration für Susannes Restaurant.
Du, guten Appetit!
Damit ich sehe,
wie schön man es anrichten kann.
Mmh!
* Ruhige Musik *
Ende Oktober war erneut Schluss
für Kunzens "Küsten-Imbiss".
Kein Lockdown, sondern Saisonende.
Doch das Leben der Familie
ist nicht ruhiger geworden,
im Gegenteil:
Die fünf Katzenbabys sind da
und halten die Familie auf Trab.
Und da war ja noch was:
Sachas Geschäftsidee
mit dem wendigen Imbisswagen.
Sie wurde Realität:
der "Küsten-Imbiss on tour".
Das hier ist unser neues Baby.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist unser neuer Wagen.
Wir haben ihn
letzten Donnerstag abgeholt.
Und ...
Ja,
jetzt machen wir eine Trockenübung,
sodass wir morgen
nicht ganz alt aussehen.
Wollen wir sehen,
was dabei herauskommt!
Mit dem gemeinsamen Projekt
"Küsten-Imbiss on tour"
haben Sacha und Kevin auch im Winter
eine Verdienstmöglichkeit.
Das mit dem Anhänger ist Neuland,
aber das ist ...
Das ist okay.
Das haben wir eigentlich im Griff.
Jetzt kommt der Elektriker dran,
der das einbauen darf.
Ja, ja, das machen wir schon.
(Kevin) Ach, ich hasse dieses Teil!
Jetzt musst du halt
in die Hocke gehen.
Du musst dich bewegen.
Nach dem zehnten Mal
hast du es im Griff.
Neben Würsten und Pommes -
Sachas Verkaufsschlagern -
bieten sie neu Raclette an.
Morgen ist Premiere.
Das Brot dazu
ist von Brigitte hausgemacht.
Es ist wirklich mal ...
Es ist wirklich
eine absolute Probephase.
Wir müssen einfach schauen,
wie viele Portionen es gibt,
wenn wir den ersten Laib machen,
und ob wir mit dem Preis, den wir
haben, die Kosten decken können.
Wahrscheinlich haben wir den Preis
ohnehin
schon relativ hoch angesetzt,
aber wir schauen mal.
Viel höher können wir mit dem Preis
nicht gehen.
Tag für Tag standen Sacha
und Brigitte hinter dem Grill
und haben gebraten und frittiert.
4,5 t Pommes gingen diesen Sommer
über die Ladentheke.
Danke! Super!
Verleidet ist Sacha dabei nur eines:
Das Einzige, das ich nicht mehr
essen kann, ist eine Currywurst.
Das ist die einzige Wurst,
die ich nicht mehr essen kann.
Alles andere,
wie z.B. eine Bratwurst,
eine Krakauer oder Pommes, geht.
Das ist eigentlich okay,
aber sonst ...
Jetzt haben wir heute
mal einen Pizzaabend.
(Kevin) Guten Appetit!
- Guten Appetit!
Ob Pizza oder Pommes ist doch wurst,
Hauptsache,
die ganze Familie ist beisammen.
Ich finde es allgemein gut,
dass Kevin hier ist.
Er gehört halt zur Familie, oder?
Wir mögen ihn alle.
Und ja, er ist mein grosser Bruder.
Es war immer
so ein Loch in der Familie,
als er noch nicht hier war.
Und jetzt, da er hier ist,
sind wir alle so vereint.
Und das ist schön, ja.
Und v.a. löst er auch Mami
bei der Arbeit ab,
dass sie öfter zu Hause ist und so.
Ihre Auswanderung war
und ist ein Familienprojekt.
Der starke Zusammenhalt war
in der Coronazeit wichtiger denn je.
Ja, es war wirklich
ein sehr ereignisreiches Jahr -
mit Höhen und Tiefen.
Aber ich glaube,
was im Endeffekt zählt, ist,
dass wir es nicht bereuen,
dass wir gerne hier sind.
Gut, hätten wir gewusst,
dass Corona kommt,
hätten wir das
wahrscheinlich nicht gemacht.
Das ist so. Das ist ... äh ...
Das haben wir
schon einige Male diskutiert.
Wir müssen da jetzt durch.
Ich glaube,
dieses Corona
wird irgendwann mal zu Ende gehen.
Jetzt müssen wir halt damit leben,
aber wir haben ja
nicht so schlecht gearbeitet.
* Ruhige Musik *
Es ist Sonntag und wie erahnt ist
das Balmoral Café bestens besucht.
Das Café
würde 130 Gästen Platz bieten.
Wegen Corona aber dürfen die Almeidas
nur gut die Hälfte bewirten.
Ui, ui, ui! Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui!
Wir können gleich noch auffüllen.
Ma'am?
- Great! Thank you very much!
Die beiden Jungs Robin und André
verdienen sich mit dem Abwasch
ein kleines Taschengeld.
Warte, warte, warte! Kann ich?
- Ja.
* Klingel *
Auch auf den Tischen liegendes
Trinkgeld dürfen die Jungs behalten.
Heute müssen alle mithelfen,
denn wir haben so viele Leute.
Es ist ein Riesenerfolg.
Jeder ist ein Teil des Zahnrads.
Nicht in die Küche!
Nicht in die Küche! Das geht nicht.
Es ist zu heiss dort drin.
Robin ... äh ... André, schau mal!
Etwas, das ich mit dir
noch besprechen wollte:
Wenn ihr erklärt, dass ihr helfen
und auch an den Trinkgeldern
beteiligt sein wollt, dann müsst ihr
wirklich helfen, verstehst du?
Kann ich nicht dort warten?
- Nein, in der Küche nicht.
Willst du mich nochmals fragen?
Gut!
Natürlich
bin ich sehr stolz auf sie.
Sie ... ähm ...
... müssen helfen,
aber sie bekommen auch etwas dafür.
Wir versuchen, sie einzubinden,
und meistens
machen sie es auch gerne.
Man muss manchmal dranbleiben,
aber es ist ein Familienbetrieb
und jeder muss anpacken.
Das ist auf einem Bauernhof
nicht anders.
Das gilt nur während des Sommers
an den Wochenenden.
Die 14-jährige Sophie erhält
als Einzige der Kinder einen Lohn:
50 kanadische Dollar pro Tag.
Sie hat einen wichtigen Job:
Sie verkauft Gebäck über die Gasse.
That's why I have to stop it.
Josefs portugiesische Puddingtörtchen
sind bereits zum Klassiker avanciert.
Du, es ist fast wieder alles weg.
Auch hier wieder:
Wenn ich zehn mache,
verkaufe ich zehn.
Wenn ich 20 mache, verkaufe ich 20.
Ich komme gar nicht mehr nach.
Ich habe jetzt aufgehört,
mich unter Druck zu setzen.
Ich mache sie einfach,
wenn ich Lust dazu habe.
Dann verkaufe ich sie.
Ich könnte sonst den ganzen Tag
in der Küche stehen
und nur davon welche machen.
Alles,
was die Familie Almeida anpackt,
scheint aufzugehen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Abendstimmung am Rio de la Plata.
Vor über einem Jahr haben Susanne
und Ruedi ihrer Heimat im Emmental
den Rücken zugekehrt -
trotz ihrer Kinder,
ihres prächtigen Hauses
und der vielen guten Freunde.
Sie haben den Fokus ihres Lebens noch
einmal komplett neu ausgerichtet.
Ich bin unglaublich dankbar,
dass wir das erleben dürfen -
dieses neue, dieses weite,
dieses wunderschöne Land,
das unsere zweite Heimat
geworden ist.
Also es erfüllt mich mit ...
Jetzt fange ich gleich an zu weinen.
Es erfüllt mich einfach mit Freude,
mit Glück.
Es ist einfach herrlich, wenn du
in ein solches Land gehen kannst
und das Privileg hast,
in einem solchen Land leben
und deinen Traum erfüllen zu können.
Wir haben dieses Privileg
und es ist schön,
nochmals einen Wechsel zu haben.
Ich liebe die Schweiz.
Ich mag die Schweiz
mit ihren Hügeln und Bergen.
Aber ich mag inzwischen auch Uruguay
sehr gerne - mit seinem Endlosen.
Ja.
Wir bereuen es nicht.
- Nein, definitiv nicht.
* Sanfte Musik *
Gleich neben EDEKA -
von Montag bis Freitag -
ist der Standplatz
von "Küsten-Imbiss on tour".
An den Wochenenden
halten alteingesessene Budenbesitzer
den Platz besetzt.
Das ist ein guter Platz, den wir
hier haben - direkt vor dem Eingang.
Besser können wir es
eigentlich gar nicht haben.
Der Stromanschluss ist auch da.
Es ist tipptopp!
Im Angebot: der Dauerbrenner Würste
und neu der Schweizer Hit:
Raclette auf Brot für 6 Euro.
Sauber!
Käse noch drauf! Hallo!
Hallo!
Pommes zum Mitnehmen?
- Ja.
Gib das Geld! Oh, geh an die Tür!
* Eine Frau lacht. *
Kommst du nicht hoch?
Ja, mache ich! Danke schön!
Und schon
die ersten Pommes verkauft.
Zack, so schnell geht das plötzlich.
(Kevin) Fühlt sich gut an, was?
Nein, jetzt bleibst du da.
So sind sie schön, was?
Du musst sie nehmen. Es ist zu hoch.
Für die Kids ist es zu hoch.
Wie kannst du nur? Also schäm dich!
- Danke euch!
Du hast den falschen Deckel
draufgetan.
Das ist jetzt unser erstes Raclette.
Wir machen es aber zuerst für uns,
um zu probieren.
Wir haben gesagt,
wir wollen erst eines machen,
bevor ein Kunde kommt -
nicht, dass wir dann alt aussehen.
Wie ein Raclette.
Ein guter Käse.
Doch keiner interessiert sich
für den geschmolzenen Käse.
So! Guten Appetit!
- (Kevin) Lass es dir schmecken!
Schönen Tag noch!
- Ja, dir auch! Danke.
Hi zusammen! Grüss euch!
Macht's gut! Tschüss! Danke! Ciao!
Na, ihr zwei?
- Hallo.
Mir läuft schon die Brille an.
Nachbar André war immer eine grosse
Unterstützung für die Familie Kunz.
Vielleicht
beisst er an beim Raclette.
Was hast du denn Schönes
zur Auswahl?
Bitte schau dort
auf unsere Speisekarte!
Ein bisschen verkleinert
im Vergleich zum Deich.
Ich nehme den Hit.
- Ja!
Gut! So ist es okay! Tipptopp!
Jetzt ist es gut.
Danke schön!
- Guten Appetit!
Danke!
- Gerne.
Riech mal!
- Klein.
Beiss mal rein, Schatz!
Ah nein,
Pommes muss er auch noch haben.
Lecker!
Zum Glück
weiss der Norddeutsche nicht,
wie eine Portion Raclette auch
mundgerecht serviert werden könnte.
Sehr gut!
Danke schön!
- Dir auch.
Die nächsten Kunden bekommen
die Portion mit Holzspiesschen.
Soll ich es halbieren?
- Das wäre nett.
Schneiden wir einmal
in der Mitte durch!
Das könntet ihr immer machen, Sacha.
Hm?
- Immer halbieren.
Ja.
So!
Das geht dann nämlich gut zum Essen.
- Ja.
Siehst du?
Haben wir dir wieder einen Tipp!
Ja, das hast du gut gemacht!
Super!
Noch ist Verbesserungspotenzial
vorhanden.
Der halbe Laib
wurde doch schon etwas kleiner.
So gesehen sind wir stolz, dass wir
das heute schon verkaufen konnten.
Ja, man sollte etwas
Mund-zu-Mund-Propaganda machen,
dann sehe ich das
für die nächsten paar Tage gut.
Ja, gelungen.
- Gelungen.
Und die beiden haben Glück:
Während des zweiten Lockdowns
dürfen sie den Wagen offen halten.
Die Blue Sea Beach.
Come on!
* Ruhige Musik *
Während andere unter der Woche
arbeiten müssen,
können sich die Almeidas
dann freinehmen.
Where are they? There he is!
Where is he?
- There.
Joe?
- Joe is there.
15 Autominuten vom Motel Balmoral
liegt das weite, offene Meer.
Cool!
Willst du das Zeug oben lassen?
Nein, nein,
das würde ich gleich mitnehmen.
Freunde haben die Familie
zum Badeplausch eingeladen.
Ja, das ist halt schon
ein Riesenvorteil in Nova Scotia:
Du kannst so schnell an den Strand.
Wenn wir Glück haben,
können wir eine Spritztour machen.
Es ist wirklich toll.
Für mich stimmt es eigentlich.
Ja, für mich hat es sich gelohnt.
Es ist das Leben, das ich mir
eigentlich vorgestellt habe.
Wir sind noch nicht ganz angekommen,
aber auf dem besten Weg dazu.
Ja.
Und je länger je mehr
haben wir gute Freunde,
Kontakte zu anderen,
die uns einladen -
eben an solch schöne Orte
und auch andere einladen.
So langsam ergeben sich
die sozialen Kontakte immer mehr.
Das ist natürlich herrlich.
So geniessen wir es ganz anders.
Das Wasser ist warm. Es ist mega.
Three, two, one ...
Für jeden gibt es
einen schönsten Ort auf der Welt.
Beatrice und Josef haben den Mut
gefasst und sich aufgemacht,
um jenen Ort zu finden, der am besten
zu ihnen und ihren Träumen passt.
Abenteuer "Auswandern".
Jedes Jahr ziehen Schweizer
und Schweizerinnen in die Welt hinaus
und wir
begleiten wieder einige von ihnen.
Hoch hinaus an der Nordsee.
Ein 120 Jahre alter Wasserturm
ist die Zukunft von Familie Caboussat
aus dem Emmental.
Nur schon das Treppenhaus
ist wunderschön.
Mir gefällt es total.
40 m über der Stadt,
im ehemaligen Wassertank,
sollen ein Café
und ein Bed and Breakfast entstehen.
Voller Elan starten die Caboussats
mit ihrem Projekt,
doch das Vorhaben
ist komplizierter als gedacht.
Man musste auch abklären,
ob im Zweiten Weltkrieg Bomben
gefallen sind und in der Nähe sind.
Die Auflagen der Behörden
sind streng.
Alles verzögert sich.
Es macht einen schon kribbelig,
denn für uns ist Zeit auch Geld.
In Ruanda wollen Dianne und Marco
Schommer aus dem Kanton Solothurn
ihr eigenes Fitnessstudio eröffnen.
Mit einem Container voller Sport-
geräte verlassen sie ihre Heimat.
Okay, okay.
Nach langer Suche finden sie
passende Räumlichkeiten in Kigali.
Baustelle pur!
- Baustelle pur!
Ich freue mich darauf,
wenn es mal fertig ist.
Jetzt weiss ich nicht,
wo ich hinsehen soll.
Der Umbau geht voran, doch der erste
Planungsfehler ist auch schon da.
Wir haben leider vergessen,
Umkleidekabinen zu machen.
Vom Fitnessclub allein können
die Auswanderer aber nicht leben.
Als zweites Standbein
pflanzen sie Zitronengras an.
Das ist wirklich nicht gut,
wenn wir das
in den Sand setzen würden.
Vom Bodensee ans Mittelmeer:
Im sonnigen Spanien
wollen Corinne und Ralf Waldburger
ein Hotel für Hunde bauen.
So können wir eigentlich,
ja, ihren Traum erfüllen -
und meinen Traum auch:
ein bisschen gärtnern.
Mi corazon.
Das Vorhaben der Ostschweizer
scheint auf gutem Weg.
Es ist bisher alles super gelaufen.
Das ist beängstigend.
Plötzlich beginnen die Probleme:
Die Baubewilligung
lässt auf sich warten
und auch die Nachbarn wehren sich.
Es ist einfach ein komisches Gefühl,
wenn du noch nicht
richtig angekommen bist und schon
die Nachbarn gegen dich hast.
Und dann kommt die Coronakrise:
Spanien steht still.
Jetzt läuft gar nichts mehr.
Einfach ... Nicht ... Nein!
Ich muss ein bisschen weg.
Nicht, dass sie zurückkommt,
wenn du ...
So, weg!
Danke, mein Held!
Wandern auch Sie aus?
Dann melden Sie sich bei unsa